Now, of course Python has a regular expression module called the "re module."
If you really want to use regular expressions, you import re and get started.
The point here is not so much to use regular expressions
as to show you what it's like to build a language processer.
So to get started doing that, I started by writing a test function
that defines some regular expressions using this API.
First I defined a, b, and c as being these literals.
Then I combine some more complicated examples.
Then I showed some example of assertions, of what we want to be true.
We've defined two functions that match the functions in the re module.
The first function is called "search."
It takes a pattern and a text, and in the regular expression module
this function returns something called a "matched object."
What we'll have it do is return a string which will be the earliest match in the text
for the pattern, and if there is more than one match at the same location,
it'll be the longest of those.
For example, search('def', 'abcdef') would return "def" because it's found there.
The next function is called "match."
It also takes a pattern and a text and returns the string that matches.
But for match, the match must occur at the very start of the string.
Search('def') would return None, indicating that there is no match.
But search('def') in this string that has 'def' at the beginning would return that match.
Here are some examples of the types of things that I want to be able to do.
That gives me the start of a specification for how I want to write my search and match functions.